now to the standoff over ukraine
russia's foreign minister met with his
british counterpart this morning and
said his country would not accept any
western ultimatum russian troops in
belarus ukraine's northern neighbor
started large-scale military drills this
morning the united states called it an
escalatory action mts tayab is in
ukraine just across the border from
those maneuvers mts good morning
good morning well this border crossing
leads to belarus where russia is holding
that massive military exercise the
largest there since the cold war and the
fear is that it could be the first step
towards an all-out invasion of ukraine
if tensions weren't already sky high
these military exercises are only adding
to the pressure of an already intense
standoff
for the next 10 days around 30 000
russian troops will carry out joint
drills right on ukraine's northern
border
the kremlin has consistently denied it
has any plans to invade
alexi danalog ukraine's top security
official says ukraine is not panicked
but is ready for anything
the russians may use belarus as a ground
for a provocation he said it could
happen at any moment
the specter of war has set alarm bells
ringing across the world cbs news has
learned of a pentagon plan to evacuate
the thousands of americans currently
living in ukraine if needed to nearby
poland where u.s forces are but not all
americans say they're willing to leave
like brian best who's lived in the
capitol key for over two decades it's
where he met his wife and is raising his
two children it's really important for
you to stay isn't it
yeah it is
how come because this is my home it's
part of my identity
now that sentiment is also felt by many
ukrainians who say not only will they
stay
but they'll fight back
tony
mts tayab for us in ukraine mts thank
you very much